hey Tony here with some gameplay from
okay kayo let's play heroes this is an
action game based on a cartoon network
show that's not actually out yet so look
for the show in August and look for the
game not too long after and if you like
what you see don't forget to Like and
subscribe
[Music]
hello kayo today is the estimated
arrival date of the new hollow foil
edition Pal cards I know I'm freaking
out Dendi yes I am also feeling related
excitement hmm do you know they're
different from regular old pal cards
hollow foil pal cards combine the latest
in predictive biometric patterning with
teleportation and vibrational warping
technologies - blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah you
started to just hear blah blah blah
correct yes tell me
so I get it the cards are portals and
you can work the here at laughs mmmm
[Music]
I hear the new hollow politician power
cards drop today I'm totes open my new
card is leveled up level 3 here I come
hey ko do you ever Pao guard yet no not
yet
get scanned bruh you never know what
deed will put you over the top I beat up
three Shannon's one day and no card next
day I helped a baby bird back into its
nest and boom carded hmm I wonder what
it's like to fight a Shannon
[Music]
uh-uh what the heck just happened you
were bouncing off the aisles and
screaming through like five minutes
Oh like I was saying you should go to
the power card machine and get skin okay
I'll go to the machine now I want to get
my hands on those whole four cards
anyway Canada take out car again no pal
card out
[Music]
[Music]
you got my card no fair
I bought three packs and none of them
had me in it sorry kale but I gotta pull
rank on you and take my car hmm what
Brad give me my card if our situations
were flipped you're thinking out loud
kale I can hear you and yeah I would do
the same for you hey gimme gimme here
you go little buddy just some card I
totally don't want Oh mean it's card
I should go show her
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
headed I got your haul of oil ignition
POW card mmm how do i unlock your powers
owie my paui what
oh come on Enid don't act like you don't
know what powers alleys are not acting
you're just saying nonsense words okay
I get it this is another one of your
cool tests isn't it
like you probably call them P Z's Oh or
um Piz easels whatever hey do you want
this POW card someone gave me they tried
to pay for their groceries with it but
it's worthless whoa
it's rats olive oil edition POW card
look were you just picking your teeth
with it yes
[Music]
hey mister guard don't tell them I told
you this but Ratan Enid are technically
your superiors see a brand needs any
help
Oh to the Kay
hi rad mr. Garr says that part of my job
at the Virginia is help you and eat it
if you need it
wait so I'm like your boss well he
didn't say that exactly read between the
lines Keo helped read if he needs it
that translates to do what I tell you to
do so this means that mr. Garr and you
and Enid are all my bosses that's
amazing I'm so lucky I can feel the
power coursing through my veins so do
you need help like stocking shelves or
something
man something way more important
someone's been messing with my van
lately I hate to even leave her alone in
the parking lot can you check on her for
me tell her I miss her whoo you sure are
close with your van rad
of course I am a solid band relationship
takes work and devotion otherwise what
we have would van inch anyway
chop-chop
[Music]
Oh rad hey hey oh why the long droopy
not tougher cool face your van is
awesome I know somebody messed with it
no that's the second time this week but
I need to catch this sicko van handed I
need to keep a constant watch over my
van until this coward tries to strike
again
I'd go out there myself but it's useless
they'll see my bulging muscles coming
and run away in sheer terror no this has
to be a stealth job scout you say ko
I need you to stick out my van in
disguise and I have the perfect disguise
for you
hi any master of disguise they'll never
see it come
smells in here
justice
[Music]
[Music]
rats precious man he could use a little
laser engraving Darrell oh wow if it
isn't Lake what's littlest loser step
away from the beautiful vehicle make me
Oh to the Kay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
whoa kayo I thought it was understood
that you were to stay by my van
indefinitely until the Vandals showed no
um the Vandals showed who was it it was
a Darrell but I took care of it and
how's my van it's fine
hmm yeah it's fine then why do you look
like you might cry I'm just so happy
that your van is fine thanks ko you're
my hero
[Music]
Rad's man isn't fine is it no box more
has it box more when rad finds out he's
gonna drop dead from a broken heart
no do eated take him to the hospital
what kid doctors do bring rad back to
life right after you tell him box more
stole his van no I have to fix this it
was my job to stake out the van and my
job to keep it safe and I failed I have
a plan but I'll need your help I need
you to load me into the Cheapskate
cannon on the bodega roof and shoot me
over to box more too dangerous cow just
tell rad what happened it wasn't your
fault and it shouldn't have been your
responsibility in the first place
Edie I'm used to you telling me what to
do and I even like it but this time I'm
telling you what to do
you're going to shoot me over to box
more in the cheapskate cannon all right
keV
but I'm coming with you no you aren't
this is between me bucks more and the
coolest fan that ever drove on four
wheels
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that's what happened to your band
Ratt I'm sorry I didn't tell you the
truth in the first place dude you had
told me that box more snatched my van
with the giant metal claw I probably
would have died of a smashed heart so
you saved my van and my life
[Music]
that tickle huh
I think I just unlocked your Powys Ali
yeah it was probably cuz I did something
extra cool more like the card could just
tell I was having a good aunt na day
you